θα πρέπει στους πρώτους που θα κάνει μι αν κρούσιαν ενδιαφέρονται να είναι άτομα από
τον αφλητισμό άτομα τα οποία πέρασαν απολύ πιάδες και να μη εν πάλι ένα πολιτικό
πρόσωπο το οποίο ίσως να μην γνωρίζε και τόσα π λλά από τν αθλητισμ σίγουρα
το εφιβουργείονται θα εξαρτάτει από ένα ανάτομα θα είναι μια ομάδα ανθρώπο το οποίοαπό κεί
θα λειτουργί ο ανθλιτισμός της κύπρου θεωρώ ότι θα έπρεπε να υπάρχου ανθρώποι του χώρου
το αθελητισμού αλλά σίγουρα και πιο τεχνο κράτες σας το πω μπορεί ναν και πολιτικά
πρόσωπα και λοιπ αλλά δεν δι ανοείταιένα σχώρος μιλάμε για τον ανθλητισμό να είναιπως ωστιαία
τις τάξεις ενανείνται σε εκατό κκαμία σχεσημαθισμό και ναδέκασε εκατό κάποιο που κάμα εναναθισμό θέρω
ότι πρέα προς την κυσ το κομμάτι ναυτό που ανθρώπος πουρίζησαν πιο βαθιά σε πολύ
ψηλότερον επίπεδο τον ανθλητισμό γιατί νομίζω έχουν κάτι να σου δώσουμε έχουν κάτι να σούπουύν
μια λεπτομέρι αντην οποία ένα θα οποίος δεν έχει ασχοληθεί δεν μπορεί να στηνπι αν
τον κυριάπουν των έπαιρνε ολικό σχριστοδουλίδης και το έλεγε κυρίπ ιο άλλουν διαφέρεσε για το
εφυπουργιο αθλητισμού θα ο θάσωθα δω καεφτόταν ο κυριά πως εννοείτε θα του σκεφτόμου γιατίναι
μιλάμε για τον αθισμό το οποίο νομίζω γνωρίζω πέντε πράγματα και μεγάλη μου χαράννα προσφέρω
δε ίναι ομοίζω ότιθα αρνι νόμουν τέτοιοπεο πράγμα χωρίς να σημαίνει ότι είναι κάτί που
θα επειδιόξο αμου ζητήσουν τη βοήθεια μου όπωτο είπα και στην νομοσπονία μου και ακόμα
και στ τότιδικό συμβουλο τουκό επιχειρισες να μς όχιόχι χι δεν ξέρω και ποια ενι
διαδικασίαος από την αλήθεια δεν επιχείρισα υπάρχει μια συνενόηση με τον προς το προσωπομου ως
εκεί δε μάλιστα